[MUSIC]
It's Sunday morning, I think.
My room is dark.
My head is the throbbing.
I have a knot in my stomach,
nausea mixed with anxiety.
[SOUND] Why did I take all
those tequila shots last night?
Why do I feel like I need to
apologize to my best friend again?
I promised myself, just like I did
last Sunday, that going forward,
things will be different.
No more shots, I am done feeling
like this when I wake up.
Week after week I made these
Sunday morning promises to myself,
only to break them by Friday night.
I just couldn't let go of alcohol.
It played a huge role in my life,
both socially and professionally.
I was afraid that if I quit drinking I
would feel different from everyone else,
or that I won't be seen
as part of the group.
Yet, I knew i could make a change.
After years of struggling to
keep my Sunday morning promises,
I finally sought support to
quit drinking last summer.
And trust me,
that was a change for the better.
I'm sure many of you
may relate to my story.
It's not that dramatic,
just a bunch of ugly Sunday mornings.
But even so,
I found quitting drinking really hard.
In the early days, I couldn't go to bars
or be around people drinking alcohol.
And I'd say I still had an easier
time than a lot of people.
For those with more ingrained addiction,
it can be nearly impossible
to quit drinking.
And if you are able to quit,
you face a world that too
often revolves around alcohol.
Getting sober has helped me understand
that keeping alcohol and such a prevalent
role in society disadvantages and
excludes those who don't drink.
Whether people abstain due to pregnancy,
religious beliefs, recovery, or
personal preference,
we are creating a divide
that keeps many non-drinkers out of
our most important conversations.
This exclusion, whether intentional or
not, means we're missing out on
the valuable untapped perspectives
of many of these people.
And we are not talking about
a small group of people here.
In fact, Alcohol.org, a subsidiary
of American Addiction Centers,
estimates that 30% of US adults
don't consume any alcohol.
And this number continues to rise
as millennials become more and
more health conscious.
There's even a new trend taking hold
called the sober curious movement.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] With the non-drinking
portion of the population on the rise,
now is the time for
us to figure out how to include everyone
in our business and social interactions.
The first thing we can
do is change our events.
Many networking events
today take place at bars.
Given my history, a bar with unlimited
alcohol is not an appealing place for
me to meet people.
For instance, earlier this year,
I was at a GSP networking event.
I was walking around in
circles without a drink,
desperately trying to find the courage
to join a group to chat with.
And let me tell you, going up to groups
of strangers at a 400-person event
with no social lubricant is really hard.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Every time I tried to join in with
someone new, they would try to hand me a
drink or ask about why I wasn't drinking.
And for the people I was talking to,
well, at the end of the night,
a lot of them weren't making any sense.
>> [LAUGH]
>> For me, the experience was miserable.
I dreaded going to future events,
but knew I had to.
Or risk missing out on the connections and
relationships that stem from
many of these interactions.
And in these situations,
I'm one of the lucky ones.
I can still tolerate going to these
events, even if I'd prefer not to.
My voice is still heard.
But many non-drinkers aren't so lucky,
and will miss out on key opportunities
by staying away from alcohol-focused
events in the name of self-care.
We can start to level the playing field
for non-drinkers by thinking about
alternative, alcohol-free ways for
us to meet and interact with one another.
Planning a hike or a cooking class as a
team event in lieu of a happy hour is all
it takes to start increasing inclusivity.
The next thing we can do is think
about the alternatives we offer.
It should be just as easy to find a soda
as it is to find a gin and tonic.
Keeping non-drinkers limited to just water
or whatever mixers are on hand while
everyone else gets to choose from
a plethora of alcoholic options,
sends a signal that non-drinkers
are an afterthought.
Or worse, weren't thought of at all.
And I don't know about you, but
when I feel like an afterthought time and
time again, I stop showing up.
If we don't show non-drinkers
that they're welcome,
they'll stop coming to our events.
Luckily, coming up with alternatives is
a really easy way to have a big impact.
Earlier this year, all of us MBA I's
participated in the Executive Challenge.
It was a full-day competition that
culminated in a squad celebration and
a class-wide cocktail hour.
As I walked to the room where my squad
would be having our post competition pow
wow, I felt dread take over me as I heard
pops of champagne coming from
every single room around me.
Great, I thought, another time where
I'll be the only person not drinking.
I begrudgingly walked to my team room,
only to see my squad fellow sitting there
with a huge smile and
a bottle of sparkling grape juice.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My mood immediately changed.
I didn't feel like an afterthought or
an outsider.
What was a small gesture from him
completely changed the way I saw my role
in the group.
Changing our events and
our alternatives are just two ways
that we can start to have an impact.
But we can have an even bigger impact by
changing our dialogue around alcohol.
About a month after I got sober, I met
some friends for brunch in San Francisco.
We sat down at our table and a waiter
came over to walk us through the menu.
When he got to the drink section,
he joked,
if you're here to have a good time,
here the cocktails.
If you're no fun, here the mocktails.
A month earlier,
I would have thought the joke was cute.
But in that moment,
it almost reduced me to tears.
I was upset about having to quit drinking.
I was feeling really different from my
friends, who could all drink normally.
I felt alone due to my inability to
participate in a favorite group pastime.
I didn't even know who I
was as a sober person.
In just one sentence, that waiter managed
to put my worst fears into words.
Now that I wasn't drinking,
I feared I'd be no fun.
Later that same day, a friend at
dinner started to make a toast.
I raised my glass of water,
hoping to go unnoticed.
>> [LAUGH]
>> However, I was quickly chastised.
Cheersing with water is bad luck.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I've thought a lot about why I drank.
About why it was so hard for
me to keep my Sunday morning promises.
For a while, alcohol was fun.
It helped me confident,
when inside I was self-conscious.
But most importantly,
it helped me feel like part of the group.
But all those illusions started to
fall away as I lost control over my
relationship with alcohol.
For me, drinking is no longer fun.
We need to change the narrative
around what is normal and fun,
when it comes to alcohol use.
Making someone feel abnormal, or
like they're no fun because
they're not drinking, is not okay.
A good rule of thumb,
keep your comments about drinking and
not drinking to yourself.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
if you hear someone making a comment that
might make a non-drinker uncomfortable,
I encourage you to be the one
to step in and make it right.
We here at the GSB have a special
responsibility to make a change.
As future leaders, society will
look to each of us as role models.
We can start to make a change today by
changing our events, our alternatives, and
our dialogue around alcohol.
So with that, I'd like to raise a toast.
>> [LAUGH]
>> With water, because it is not bad luck.
>> To each of us here today.
Each of us has the power to leave
this room and make a difference,
both here at the GSB and beyond.
So cheers to changing the future.
To creating environments where both
drinkers and non-drinkers can thrive,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]